hey everyone diabolo here and in today's
video we are back for my third video in
the JoJo steel Bull Run Series in the
last video we watched is our four main
characters along with a few others like
the British racing Legend Dio or the
Egyptian fire monk evdal all did their
best on the first stage and gained that
important one hour time bonus and this
next part of my steel will run series we
move on to the first section of the
second stage the second stage takes the
first and makes it seem like a taste
tester in terms of what's to come
instead of a basic Sprint to find out
who is insane horse riding skills this
now takes all of the remaining Riders
and makes them push for the next 1200
kilometers in a grueling Race Across the
desert Plains of America so if you are
new around here and want to keep up to
date as I release the steel Bull Run
series then subscribe and if you do
enjoy it as well then make sure to leave
a like as it really helps out with
pushing my content to a bunch of new
amazing people but enough of that sit
back and relax as we dive into the
Arizona desert Arc of Steel will run
[Applause]
so before we actually get underway with
the beginning of the second stage we see
that because of what they just
discovered at the end of The Last Arc
the sheriff is asking Stephen to
postpone the race even if it was only
for a moment pondering the idea for a
moment to himself Steven throws it aside
as he believes it's already too late and
everyone involved in the race is giving
it their all and his eyes postponing it
is impossible figuring that he was going
to say that anyway the sheriff informs
Steven that that was the exact reason as
to why he had already requested Mountain
temp to pursue all potential suspects
while the two stand there discussing
Mountain term Wyoming's only ever anime
character finally makes his appearance
funnily enough the reason I say that is
because this man somehow managed to get
fourth in the first stage event without
us even noticing him once and some Next
Level Mr steal your girl's smoothness
temples up behind Lucy let's use some
nearby flowers that match your dress and
ask if she's already married while
offering those Sid flowers to her
Stephen swimming balls over the fact
that Tim's trying to steal Lucy weirdly
gases him up or mentioning that mountain
Tim as a legendary cowboy who has a huge
potential to win so it makes no sense
for him to take this random request this
year who's thought this all through with
Tim points out that mounted Tim as an
important person and due to that once
the second stage starts there's a high
probability of mountain time being
targeted by the suspect nearby on his
deed Tim absorbs the area looking down
he notices these weird looking patterns
on the ground the patterns portray a
unique method of killing one that he's
heard Legends of similar deaths about so
you see there's an old Indian Legion
that speaks of a shooting star that fell
somewhere inside of the Arizona desert
it's said that if anything touches the
spot of the tainted soil that person or
item will be able to pull out a
mysterious power from inside of itself
at the same time though evil spirits
will call out a deathly curse upon them
knowing of the said curse none of the
natives ever stepped foot in that land
that also said that a white man came
looking for him or in the desert and
stepped inside of this spot then
returned home sadly once he did arrive
home he took out others in a terrifying
fashion before any moment of sudden
realization for what he'd done took
himself out back in Arizona now Tim
states that the first thing he is going
to do is track down the person who has
this very specific Mountain shaped
marking on their horse Hooves Stephen
doesn't think some random markings on a
horseshoe Tim saw is going to change
anything but Tim lets him know that it
does through reading the markings on the
ground he can see that a person's horse
went crazy after what the rider had done
wondering if they checked out the random
bottle next to the victims Tim points
out that there's something inside of it
on closer inspection and realizing that
it's a button Mountain 10 was like the
craziest use of Alesso anyone's ever
seen casually controls it to grab the
button inside to inspect it even closer
looking at it everyone starts wondering
about the connection of this object with
the murders how did this button even end
up in the air the only thing that's for
certain is that whoever did this is
truly a dangerous killer and this
evidence is important I love hit like
random JoJo says like this is all just
so Random at the moment like there's no
connection that we can even make to like
how Tim's controlling player it's all
just so Random anyways anyways with only
five minutes to go until the next stage
begins all of the spectators begin
getting hyped of the next section of
Racine stage two takes us from the Santa
Maria Novella Church all the way through
to the Monument Valley in Arizona there
are over 3 700 participants still in the
race but they'd expected to take
anywhere from 12 to 18 days to complete
the stage bringing everyone back to
reality the commentator screams for
everyone to take their starting
positions unlike the first stage he
tells them that each competitor is
allowed to freely choose their own route
through the deserts obviously with the
exception of passing through
pre-designated checkpoints if a player
for any reason is forced to retire from
the race then their respective number
will be shown as Flags above the road on
top of that covered wagons with medicine
food and water will be following at a
fair distance behind the race just to
make sure that everyone has a fair
chance of survival and saw the hustle
and bustle at the start of the grid
Johnny along with gyro and I I know I
can't believe that the first two videos
now I went and stuffed up Gyro's name I
I really thought it was like gyroscopic
like that's how I thought you said
gyroscopic but it's not it's gyroscopic
and now I just I feel like the biggest
egg on the entire planet I think I hit
up Nika the guy's doing like the
thumbnails for this and asked him and I
was just oh my I can't believe I did it
anyway continuing on along with gyro
they both seem to be discussing the
other top competitors after hearing that
sandman's ranked number one in the
popularity poll gyro asks about his own
rank only to instantly get hit with a
cruel reality that he's lower ranked
than his teammate coming in at Ninth
well Johnny was sixth reading further
into it Johnny explains that if Sandman
does manage to take first again his
points will increase up to 200 and he'll
accumulate two hours and time bonuses if
that happens he'll live an overwhelming
advantage over pretty much any other
competitor gyro being like the
straightforward man he is starts
wondering if Sandman could actually run
over 100 kilometers in one day looking
up Johnny reveals that he's afraid so
plus just to make the entire situation
worse for them and better for Sandman he
states that Sandman is from Arizona so
technically this is his home turf
glancing over any nearby jockey Johnny
knows that the man he's looking at
mountains him as just as popular as them
and a huge candidate for the section of
the race mountain term is a cowboy so it
makes sense in Johnny's eyes for him to
have terrible short range but fantastic
long-range stamina however he managed to
sneak up and even pass them under the
last section of the first stage without
making a single sound gyro jokes that it
was because of his funky head not
listening to him though and or browsing
the map Johnny realizes that this
section will become a battle over water
unlike the first short section the
second one will put people to tests in
all kinds of ways and the distance they
travel all depends on if they can make
the journey without running out of
fluids bringing up an old incident in
the desert Johnny explains to Garo that
an entire Cavalry unit vanished out of
the blue one day it wasn't due to war or
an accident caused by man no in that
year every water hole had dried up
leaving the helpless unit to make the
Trek through the desert to look for an
alternative water source one day they
noticed the temperature start to rise
past its usual amount still they
continued forth until every last man had
died of dehydration hours before they
perished small cracks formed and their
own dried up eyeballs causing them to
all go blind even blind they continued
to wander aimlessly through the infinite
desert being slowly roasted by the sun
to prevent such an event happening to
them Johnny dots out the planned
direction to go to the first water point
and from there Head East to the second
water Point drowning out Johnny's
conversation the announcer screams that
there's only 30 seconds before the
beginning of the second stage in front
and ready to go Theo pulls up his
goggles while everyone's favorite Poco
Loco has all of his sex tied up and
ready to go on the back of a Steed with
it heading 10 AM fireworks are sit-off
signaling the start of the second stage
instantly and following them the same
game tracks as last time gyro once again
pushes are here to take first place
early on in the race confused with his
level of speed already Johnny just
wonders what in the world is wrong with
this man can he really keep this up for
an entire stage then and a change of
events that Johnny wasn't even privy to
jarrow changes Direction and begins
darting off to the north east following
him Johnny quickly takes the turn
himself simultaneously the amount of
Screams that it looks as if jarrow is
aiming to cut across the entire
Wasteland and ignore all plotted out
water holes screaming Johnny asks his
boy what the hell he's up to he pleads
for some kind of reason for this
unnecessary use of speed hashing home
jarrow just says that others are gonna
do the same plus this is the shortest
route so this way they can easily pass
everyone even Sandman as gyro and Johnny
are continuing to boost it towards the
Northeast the announcer lets them all
know that a mysterious follower has
joined their tale zooming in they see
that a person in Hot Pursuit of the
leading Duo is a random competitor
called Mrs Robinson who unbeknownst to
everyone supposedly has those weird
Mountain shaped horseshoes
having pushed around 150 horses in front
of the random competitor Johnny gets out
his trusty book and confirms that this
person is Mrs Robinson on the other hand
he informs Jairo that they're almost six
hours away from the starting point now
and they should have reached the top of
the mountain they're on about now before
moving forth he just needs to make sure
that they're on the right Trail because
if they get caught in the wrong spot the
larger Mountains will be impossible for
them to pass standing nearby and
examining the map himself jarrow doesn't
give any response and just dwells on the
map flicking it around multiple times
trying his best to read hers speaking up
he's skeptical yet he still reassures
Johnny that they're going in the right
direction maybe annoyed with being told
maybe Johnny rages out screaming that
it's 80 kilometers to the closest water
hole and if they do to it even slightly
from the course then they run the risk
of death trying to push past this
confrontation gyro asks Johnny about how
the revolutions he told him to practice
for the cork are coming along shutting
the two of them up though in an instant
a random really fast object passes right
between the duo catching them by
surprise wondering what it was they snap
their heads around to see a rider slowly
coming up from behind the duo what
confused Garo though about all of this
was the fact that the thing didn't
really come from behind but rather from
someone in front Barefoot with it Johnny
just points out to gyro that his ear has
almost been shot clean off by whatever
that thing was in the same moment Johnny
is also hit by this weird Force causing
scratches and cuts to appear all over
his body gyro starts panicking screaming
that is coming from in front of them
turning around once more he now observes
the racer running parallel to him and
Johnny noticing the weird direction of
the attacks Johnny states that has to be
coming from in front and it probably
means someone is still hiding in the
shadows still after pulling out a cactus
needle from his wound he remembers a
story about a type of cactus that was
able to shoot out its needle called a
chola when an animal or something draws
close to these plants as a response to
the vibrations coursing through the
ground the cactus will shoot out its
needles pointing out that the dude is
like way out of even rifle range in his
eyes it's frankly impossible to think
that the plants will purposefully aiming
for him off his vibrations Garo States
though that if this dude did happen to
have a motive then it is a possibility
that he also isn't worried about
receiving a penalty for attacking
someone and in reality wants them
removed from the race coming to the
realization that they are in a truly
dangerous position and with the rider
turning in their Direction now gyro
advises Johnny to start running doing so
Johnny leans down to grab his reins yet
in that moment they're pissed by a
volley of Chola Dart which in turn
throws Johnny's white placement off
causing him to begin falling off his
horse then on top of that another
extremely accurate blast of Troller
darts heads under rexley in the face
sending them crashing into the ground
having turned to look back at his
falling partner gyro was also hit with a
barrage of choler darts luckily for him
he was able to chuck up his arm and time
to protect his face gyro believed that
this has been Mrs Robinson's and 10 from
the very start and asks Johnny to get up
on his horse already so they can leave
and continue the race with blood
beginning to Blind his eyes Johnny while
crawling just screams out that Garo
needs to abandon him and keep going he
knows he promised to cross the line with
him but he can't forget that at the end
of the day they asked the rivals this is
a race there is no reason for him to
wait and Johnny's blood-soaked eyes
he'll just have to catch back up after
he's fit enough to ride gyro like the
actual King he is though it's just like
don't worry bro I got you don't worry
about a damn thing both Rivals so I'll
head off however the direction he ends
up hitting often is towards the mental
case that supposedly damaged his boy
boasting off in the direction of Mrs
Robertson Garo pulls out both of his
steel balls and prepares to loot them
loose by activating the spin noting this
and remembering the first stage Johnny
advises him to not use them as he got a
warning on the previous section and if
he messes up now there won't be another
chance but you know General doesn't
really listen to anyone else other than
himself so in the end he bursts the
balls to rexley and Mrs Robertson
however as soon as he does that jarrow
ends up taking a burst of choler dance
to both arms causing both of his steel
balls to fall down into the desert sand
so I'm going to
opponent reveals these small weird
flying bugs that crawl out of the
location his left eye used to be in then
all of a sudden going on a little bit of
a tangent here and according to Mrs
Robinson well this man is highly
influenced by the tradition of a small
village with a loser of an argument
would get tied up against a cactus the
idea behind this is that the remaining
life they lived would be a slow and
agonizing one after their passing even
the cactus would place a curse on the
dead man and due to that said curse it
was brought back from the dead to be a
slave to Revenge avenging a grudge that
could never be resolved turns out that
this was the village of Mrs Robinson and
in order to separate himself from the
others he used a special technique on
his body one that allowed him to race in
six inside of himself the reason Italy
Reveals His vital piece of information
is because now in the race he's using
those hit and six to fly around and set
off all of the Chola Cactus needles
instantly and will be bugs having fallen
past some more cactuses and sends a
plethora of needles shooting towards
both Johnny and Gyro screaming like some
evil villain Robinson states that he
won't allow anyone in this race to run
in front of him paved with us to who's
weird it is go just asks if he thought
he could forget all about his precious
steel balls that he knocked to the
ground earlier looking around and
noticing a small dust cloud appearing at
the base of his horse's feet Joe tells
Mrs Robertson that he might not be as
accurate with his aim but that doesn't
matter the vibrations of the revolutions
are now synced up exactly with him and
his location meaning that he literally
made his Escape impossible with
vibrations connecting with all of the
choler around it seems a huge barrage of
needles from every direction that was
physically impossible to Dodge in time
and subsequently probably killed Mrs
Robinson so skipping forth a little
while later and still following in those
same weirdly shaped horse tracks
Mountain Tim comes across Mrs Robinson's
horse but you've been left abandoned
after his previous battle chicken is
fate Tim confirms that this wasn't the
murderer's horse as its shoe has a
completely different design but he's
definitely on the right track as the
Horseshoes his looking for posture these
pots around 30 minutes previous to his
arrival
so that that brings us to the end of
what is the third Arc in the steel will
run Series this Ikea was a great start
when it comes to I I guess just how
weird JoJo's can get it is one of the
shorter ones and we do get a bunch more
like this which is a huge change just
from like what I'm usually used to with
other series I don't know if what you
call Mrs Robinson head a stand but it
very much is a possibility I'm just not
100 sure myself so let me know Down
Below in the comment section if you know
that this was like a stand in Mrs
Robinson had or it was just some like
weird gimmicky ability that they've got
kind of like gyro steel balls at this
moment and the fourth Arc of this series
we do a little backstory deep diving as
we look at who gyro was before coming to
America along with a very important
nine-year-old boy named Marco on a real
note they'll short some of these story
arcs are so much happens throughout them
and it's great seeing how much Iraqi has
improved his storytelling as we move
through SBR if you have enjoyed this
video though and want to watch more
stuff just like it but for a multitude
of different series then be sure to hit
that subscribe button and leave a like
down below for those wondering if I'm
going to actually stop the series for
any reason because I've seen a few
comments asking me if I'm doing it or
not no I of course I'm definitely not
stopping this series like anyone on this
platform I definitely do care about
views but I also just want to talk about
what I want to talk about so don't worry
I I'm not going anywhere with still Bull
Run and I've actually got some massive
plans when I eventually merge all of the
parts together by the way if you do want
to support me more though feel free to
check out the patreon to get early
access to videos and just random q and
A's for me every now and then by the way
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and I will see you
all in a bit bye